enfin ils vont toucher au but
ce groupe de ch'ti a fait 200 km de
cambrai pour un voyage organisé depuis
des mois voir la butte montbrison va
s'installer voir avec ses potes devant
les vignes de montmartre etc etc
le funiculaire du temps mais nos sept
lecteurs on a des choix de titres ainsi
on est allés au théâtre tél
on n'était pas loin de mon marché quand
on a vu que les ruelles montrer c'est
vraiment forte
nadine est l'une des organisatrices des
sorties de ce groupe et montmartre reste
un incontournable qu'est ce que ça vous
évoque montmartre je vais réparer autant
de la peau m
la bohème de charles aznavour avec tout
ce que tout ce que dit la chanson en
fait voilà c'est ça c'était le mot le
temps pour moi les gens se posaient pas
de questions ils vivaient en fait avec
pas grand chose mais ils vont être
surpris
la butte ne ressemble plus vraiment à
l'image d'épinal qu'ils ont en tête
attention en descendant s'il vous plaît
parce que nous sommes sur le pouvoir de
circulation
d'abord l'accueil n'est pas franchement
chaleureux mais ils veulent pas monter
trop remplir le train ce matin là le
conducteur du petit train veut
absolument remplir ses wagons lui il
n'est pas en vacances
il a des horaires à respecter les fours
en câbles train
sinon le rapace mai
chez les ch'tis et pour cause montmartre
est un des lieux les plus visités de
paris 8 millions de personnes
grimpe l'adulte chaque année ici le
point de repère c'est la basilique du
sacré-coeur la butte a toujours été un
quartier atypique de paris elle a attiré
de célèbres artistes comme picasso ou
apollinaire
une histoire qui fait aujourd'hui la
fortune des guides en 1814
ce sont les russes qui occupent
montmartre encore ils ont très soif ils
vont demander à voir vite vite vite vite
évita russe des bistrots des bistrots
partout toute la journée des groupes
belges russes japonais arpente sans
relâche la plus haute colline de paris
sur les traces d'amélie poulain
[Musique]
n'a pas l'impression qu'on est dans par
des coups on a l'impression d'être dans
une petite ville dans un petit village
en plus il fait tellement beau qu'on
m'aime pas l'impression d'être dans nord
enfin dans le nord au sud de la loire
selnor mais la plupart des touristes ne
se contente pas de voir la butte
ils descendent aussi sur un autre
quartier mythique de la capitale
pigalle une grande avenue bordée de
sex-shop réputée pour sa vie nocturne
l'amour tarifé et la débauche son
emblème le cabaret du moulin
en revanche il évite un autre secteur
pourtant juste à côté château rouge et
la goutte d'or des quartiers
traditionnellement connue pour le trafic
de drogue et la misère à seulement
quelques rues ces deux mondes cohabitent
sans jamais se mélanger avec une
frontière le boulevard barbès
or la totalité de cet arrondissement le
18e est en pleine mutation
à chaque coin de rue des surprises vont
balayer les clichés des touristes ils
sont loin de s'imaginer à quoi ressemble
aujourd'hui une vie de peintre sur la
butte
françois refait au devra affronter une
concurrence inattendue autres
personnages surprenants
isabelle chercher ce ski qui doit se
battre pour sauver son commerce et enfin
sophie buis capitaine de police
toujours sur la brèche dans un quartier
beaucoup moins calme qu'il n'y paraît
[Applaudissements]
une des activités les plus étonnantes de
l'arrondissement se trouvent place du
tertre au coeur de montmartre
elle est investie par des dizaines de
peintres c'est le plus grand marché de
peinture de paris et dans les rues
avoisinantes des galeries vente aussi
tableaux sur tableau mais toutes ses
toiles
d'où viennent elles
jusqu'où sont prêts à aller ces
commerçants pour vendre et comment
certains récupère t-il les miettes de
cet énorme business à montmartre les
qu'il arrive le touriste est assailli
par les portraitistes
[Musique]
paul laszlo et caricaturiste il traîne
ses basques ici depuis 40 ans ils
arrêtent les gens et les crocs en
quelques minutes et pour cela il a une
technique bien rodée madame hadja beau
jeu mais madame est très belle le gros
truc c'est le charme
d'abord le chat mademoiselle est
merveilleuse des appareils hp on tombe
en amour et qu'est ce que vous faites ce
soir ici regardez combien paul travaille
tous les jours en général l'après midi
parfois jusqu'à 11 heures du soir
voilà cette caricature mais très sympa
[Musique]
la fusée volant
notre méchant non ça va
sur dix pensent ça dépend de mon énergie
si je me sens d'attaqué si je change jeu
quand faire deux je peux en faire quatre
je peux en faire dix et il fait s'est
pris un peu à la tête du client
là ils demandent 35 euros à ces
touristes d'un onglet mais n'y as pas la
nourrit mes fans
[Musique]
pourquoi vous avez fait payer 35 les
danois et 20 la dame
parce que j'ai envie aux clients
je fais mon prix et si les gens sont pas
contents pour contexte mmm ont pris ben
décembre si moi j'ai besoin d'argent et
si et si et si on va discuter c'est
quand marché paul n'a pas voulu nous
dévoiler ses revenus derrière l'image
bohème de la butte
le commerce n'est jamais loin des
portraitistes nous ont confié gagné
pendant l'été jusqu'à 1000 euros par
semaine mais ils sont nombreux à courir
le touriste alors pour les attraper
certains artistes se transforment en des
marcheurs aux méthodes musclées
démonstration nous avons équipé deux
journalistes de caméras cachées elles se
font passer pour des touristes
à peine arrivé alors qu'elles n'ont rien
demandé de portraitiste se jette sur
elle
cellartis est d'accord mais c'est
combien la portraitiste à une technique
surtout ne pas parler d'argent
le principe forcer la main souvent le
touriste n'ose plus refuser
oui c'est sa supplication soyez sages
pouvons tenir les gens sa méthode c'est
de baisser les prix tout en continuant à
dessiner ses converse 60 d'accord 30
le dessin est quasiment terminé le prix
définitif n'est toujours pas fixée à
force d'insister la portraitiste tranche
gouffre a pas d'accord si vous des
messages n'étaient pas venus en pensant
que j'allais me faire destiné
[Musique]
le ton ne met pas la réplique
le piège se referme le touriste est
coincé mais notre journaliste ce
religieux pas votre endroit c'est pas
beau pas une faute au sol les
portraitistes commence à s'énerver vous
à des professionnels va pas vous changer
vie finalement nos journalistes h est
malgré tout un croquis à 20 euros mais
on est très loin de l'ambiance bon
enfant que les visiteurs ont en tête en
venant à montmartre ça vous convient je
suis désolé mais c'est pas grave c'est
pas cool au revoir
ce que ne savent pas les touristes c'est
que ces portraitiste travaillent dans
l'illégalité ils n'ont aucune
autorisation pour vendre ainsi dans la
rue
[Musique]
il n'y a pas d'accord du tout il dure
aux d'inframed épaules comme les autres
risquent chaque jour des amants il est
ce que l'on appelle un volant car à
montmartre il existe deux types
d'artistes ceux qui battent le pavé
comme lui et les peintres officiels eux
ils sont cantonnés sur la place du
tertre et non pas le droit d'en bouger
un règlement que paul a toujours refusé
l'artiste est devenue un thème jardins
d'ailleurs de sa position artistes qui
parle à tout le monde comme ce que
j'essaie de faire
devenu un être stratifié dans un mètre
carré interdiction de bouger de parler
donc les gens défilent comme au bois de
boulogne
mais celle-là je veux celui là je veux
celle là combien ont tari fait les prix
on y va et achat je ne supporte pas je
supporte 300 artistes se partagent cette
place du tertre suivant des règles
extrêmement précise et rejoindre le
cercle très fermé des peintres officiels
s'apparente au parcours de combattant
notre enquête nous emmène dans un
restaurant historique de la place
françois orfeo y est maître d'hôtel ça
c'est le petit venir
cela fait huit ans qu'ils rêvent
d'obtenir une place de peintre car la
restauration ce n'est pas sa vraie
vocation
c'est un métier assez stressant et
j'aspire à deux ans près alizés c'est
bien oui c'est bon oui pas de problème
j'aspire à faire quelque chose de plus
relax
artiste dans l'âme il veut vivre de sa
passion et dans trois semaines il espère
bien à 57 ans réaliser enfin son rêve
est passé de l'autre côté de cette
barrière
merci bonne journée
voilà j'espère bien qu'elle serait
autant d'argent en tant que peintre très
appréciable ici au savary
ça peut varier entre 2005 38 il espère
gagner 2500 euros par mois mais pour
avoir le droit d'exercer ici les
artistes doivent se plier à des
démarches bureaucratiques
ça c'est la liste des pièces à fournir
vous avez justificatif de domicile
boro de situation fiscale avant il y
avait un casier judiciaire et je crois
que les premières années ont donné un
casier judiciaire
moi ça me fait tellement longtemps
maintenant j'ai oublié mais bon mais
voilà c'est simple et on vous a déjà
fait passer des tests ça va alors on par
contre on vous demande des photos deux
oeuvres n'importe quoi est ce qu'on vous
a fait passer un test pour voir si selon
l'ond non non non sur la place du tertre
le principe c'est l'ancienneté
aucun critère artistique n'entre en jeu
chaque année seulement cinq ou six
places se libèrent quand des artistes
parc où meurent et les postulants sont
nombreux
le lendemain françois orfeo est convoqué
dans une annexe de la mairie de paris au
très officielle du rau du commerce non
sédentaire
ça y est sur un petit bout de carton des
artistes oui c'est un grand jour
monsieur je vais chercher ma carte pour
lequel cette carte je lui donne le droit
de vendre ses toiles
tous les artistes de la place ont un
statut de commerçant
je veux aller chercher la carte de
monsieur je vais vous demander une
petite signature sur le pet food a
repris mais bienvenue sur le carré
monsieur merci qui voilà je vous en prie
cette carte il l'a maintenant avis
dessus un numéro le 58
c'est son emplacement imposées par
l'administration
il ne devra pas le quitter il se trouve
relégué tout au fond de la place
derrière les terrasses de café
cela dit si un ici ce petit carré
envoyer ses marques et 58 celle qui 58
ans fait à peu près un mètre carré le
principe c'est d'avoir la place déjà
bonnes ou mauvaises
bon je suis pas sur les champs-elysées
comme comique et à l'autre côté ce qu'il
appelle les champs elysées c'est cette
allée où les affaires marchent le mieux
par laquelle tous les touristes passent
ce sont les anciens qui sont ici
françois lui commencera dans trois
semaines à la fin de son contrat avec le
restaurant et il est loin de s'imaginer
la redoutable concurrence qu'il devra
affronter
tous ces visiteurs ne voit qu'une infime
partie du xviiie arrondissement au pied
de la butte à quelques minutes de la
fourmi un autre monde que les touristes
n'imagine même pas
château rouge le quartier africain de
paris c'est la plaque tournante du
commerce exotiques dans le nord de la
france particuliers et grossistes font
des centaines de kilomètres pour acheter
ici des produits introuvables ailleurs
un commerce énorme parfois plus ou moins
légales qui pose des problèmes au
commissariat du xviiie arrondissement
donc opération répression le but c'est
de faire une énorme tenaille sorte à
maintenir sur site le maximum de
marchandises une opération de grande
ampleur se prépare elle est organisée
une fois par mois à sa tête la capitaine
sophie but vous et intervenir donc là ce
qu'on va faire c'est que vous allez
partir à 2 minutes chacun d'intervalle
trente deux hommes pas moins sont
mobilisés tous ces policiers sont en
civil car ils doivent agir par surprise
pour réussir leur mission
parfois lorsqu'on a des stagiaires ou
des élèves qui viennent dans nos groupes
sur une ou deux semaines et bien pour
nous c'est un bon moyen aussi les
utiliser et parce que ces gens là sont
pas connues et puis on les un filtre sur
ce sur ce genre de
deux secteurs et voilà ça nous permet
d'avoir des indics de nouveau indiqué
pendant que les policiers se prépare à
château rouge le commerce bat son plein
diarra vient de banlieue parisienne pour
faire ses courses
elles recherchent des produits
typiquement sénégalais les paiements je
vais le prendre là bas enfin ça me
rappelle quand j'étais tout petit et que
j'accompagnais ma maman à faire le
marché
les joues rouges avait pas école en une
après midi
diarra fait le plein pour la semaine
bissap une sorte de deuil manioc banane
plantain gombo un légume un peu gluante
350 boutiques proposent tout ce qu'on
trouve sur le continent noir
mais plus surprenant on achète ici en
france des produits aujourd'hui
introuvable en afrique
diarra se rend dans une des plus grandes
poissonnerie de château rouge
sa particularité le poisson congelé en
mer directement importées d'afrique le
plus recherché c'est celui ci le mérou
la rsa moi j'étais au sénégal mais je
n'ai pas calé sur terre ne pas manger
[Musique]
son tour être viré ya des gros bateaux
qui viennent et essaient tout fait que
des poissons les gros poissons
et que les mêmes à l'étranger ce magasin
vend au détail mais aussi en gros la
clientèle est internationale
cette petite poissonnerie ou le 18e
exporte en allemagne en suisse et en
belgique
une vingtaine de grossistes défilent
chaque semaine cette commerçante par
exemple d'habitude elle prend 400 kg par
mois pour les revendre au détail dans sa
boutique de la région parisienne des
poissons de 5 à 10 kg passe de main en
main
au choix une quinzaine d'espèces mérous
et la pia shachar plapla la nouvelle
gueule et chaque nationalité a ses
préférences
quand ils viennent ils demandent la
grosse hall savent être directement que
c'est un camerounais un sénégalais
arrive il va vous demander un gameiro
grande offre
vous savez cette entreprise écoule entre
une et trois tonnes de poissons par jour
ils sont pesées puis découpé à la scie
si ça marche aussi bien ce n'est pas un
hasard
dans ce quartier les clients de petits
budgets et le poisson congelé coûte deux
fois moins cher que le ferait autour de
ces boutiques exotiques se développe un
peu comme en afrique une économie
parallèle celle des vendeuse à la
sauvette
une particularité du quartier des femmes
propos sur le trottoir ses légumes
violer des ça fout
chez les plus de la plus rentable pour
ça on le tourne alors au cameroun pour
congo zaïre à la guinée équatoriale des
gens qui viennent qui viennent du voyage
au pays
et puis qui lui livre ça ces acheteurs
importants gros puis fournissent les
vendeuses à 5 euros les 10 elle en
écoule chaque jour des kilos en toute
illégalité l'époque laquelle ces femmes
sans emploi n'ont aucune autorisation
pour vendre dans la rue pour faire
tranquillement leur petit commerce
elle affirme s'être arrangé avec les
boutiques du coin
l'avion de la boutique nous en dit plus
que nous vendons déjà fin et n'a pas
d'impact romain dhr que nous vendons au
moins ça qu'ils vendent autour de nous
on a joué on a on accepter des ventes
que c'est un accord que vous apporte le
week-end plus de 50 femmes se font
concurrence et chaque rue a sa
spécialité
ici le coin de l'alimentaire les ça fou
et le maïs chaude tout juste cuit les
vents du brûlant encore fumant
un peu plus loin les bijoux et la
maroquinerie les femmes d'origine
africaine vente des sacs des hommes
d'origine pakistanaise des ceintures et
des portefeuilles
c'est un véritable marché très organisés
que dénoncent certains commerçants
excédés par cette présence envahissante
on pourrait aller sur les trottoirs qui
nous en met aussi à la base c'est ça on
nous a fait retirer nos étalages pour ça
parce que les habitants du quartier
panique avait plus de passages violents
mais d'autres pourraient prévoir tout de
même que ça change car ces vendeuses
sont ici chez elle elle récupère des
chaises des cartons et s'installe quand
elles partent elles laissent tout sur
place
ce qui exaspère les habitent
au commissariat du xviiie arrondissement
l'intervention de cet après-midi vise
justement ce commerce parallèle
les policiers en civils quittent le
commissariat au compte gouttes pour ne
pas se faire repérer chacun va prendre
sa position peu à peu ils encerclent le
quartier
mais subitement avant même le lancement
de l'intervention
les vendeuses se met à courir dans tous
les sens
soit on pour l'enfant dit sophie lui
elle ne se doute de rien top départ pour
l'opération
quand elle arrive surprise plus de
vendeuse que des cartes
[Applaudissements]
il ya un problème et je pense qu'elles
ont dû être avisé parce que regarder il
ya plus personne donc voilà c'est le
problème récurrent quoi en fait c'est un
jeu perpétuel entre le chat et la souris
et voilà quoi donc c'est un petit peu
fatigant pour nos fonctionnaires et puis
euh euh ben on va évidemment ils sont
toujours gagnants dans le dans le match
mais ils ont été prévenus c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible
ils m'ont dit que c'était blindé des
guetteurs sont en effet posté dans tout
le quartier pour avertir les vendeuses
car les policiers sont très identifiable
tous les jours ils patrouillent en
uniforme et ce sont les mêmes qui
participent aux opérations en civil
alors voilà ce que ça donne donc là
c'est l'exemple parfait
la fonctionnaire de police qui est
parfaitement connue sur secteur
donc toutes les femmes je dirais pas
adule mais repousse parce que parce
qu'elles savent qu'il est là pour
quelque chose et voilà les policiers ont
tout de même fait une trouvaille
intéressante donc ça c'est aussi l'heure
des crèmes blanchissantes sont très très
dangereuse donc à base de cortisone qui
sont scrupuleusement interdite
à la banque comme ça donc juridiquement
qualifie ça comme l'exercice illégal
d'une profession de pharmacien la
vendeuse de ces crèmes risque jusqu'à
deux ans de prison et 30000 euros
d'amendé vérification dont vous suivrez
au commissariat l'adoption de thé au
québec 18 ans l'opération est terminée
des policiers ont tenu prennent ensuite
le relais ils restent sur place pour
éviter que les vendeuses ne se
réinstalle aujourd'hui le butin est
plutôt maigre des crèmes quelques sacs
une dizaine de ceinture tu l'appelles à
deux rues de là les vendeuses nous
prennent à partie nous ne sont pas des
assassins
il y a des gens qui font de la drogue tu
vas tu prenais pas pourquoi mais nous on
voit jusqu'à la sauver en tenue ou en
civil les policiers passent trois ou
quatre fois par jour
du coup ils ont écopé de petits nous ya
un cautionnement de robots l'autre on
l'appelle hong kong ont à peine de quoi
ce qui pèse 350 kg gratuite à trappes 8e
jette à terre ce qu'on appelle mono
moment la peine parce qu'il est beau en
otage
c'est le voeu de poursuivre quand j'ai
le court c'est plus que même un chien
belga les cheveux blancs il s'appelle
soit prononcée en appel sous tutelle
homme aux cheveux blancs certaines
vendeuses prennent des contraventions
pour embarras de la voie publique et
vente illégale jusqu'à 350 euros
d'autres se font confisquer leurs
marchandises à paris pour la brousse
anormal elle s'appuyait c'est ça le
business des jeux qui gagnent tu rigoles
du coup tu perds tu pleures mais c'est
pas pour elle ce jeu du chat et de la
souris c'est la routine
n'at-il pas dans tel talent a dévié en
fumée oui toute la journée ter est parti
fort le jabal open au travail mais à
quelques centaines de mètres quand tombe
la nuit se déroule un tout autre marché
là ce n'est plus une simple vente au
détail mais un commerce d'une autre
ampleur échange de copies de grandes
marques bracelets montres sacs ceintures
ou t-shirts par dizaines sous les yeux
des passants pendant une heure des
acheteurs se procure ici ce qui sera
revendue à la sauvette ailleurs le
lendemain
on
[Musique]
retour sur la butte montmartre un petit
matin de novembre
la place évident françois orfeo va
entamer sa première journée d'artistes
comme nouveaux peintres face à l'énorme
concurrence
va-t-il réussir à vendre ses toiles mais
généralement les touristes arrivent vers
9h30 8h30 voilà je suis peut-être un peu
de réussite et surtout un peu stressé il
n'a pas l'habitude de monter son petit
stand
trop tôt mais seuls sont dehors comme ça
c'est parce que ça fait les petits bébés
quand ses voisins sont installés en dix
minutes
lui ne sait toujours pas comment
équilibrer son chevalet j'ai pas des
automatiques comme vous et c'est
françois orfeo aujourd'hui c'est un test
il va se frotter au regard critique de
ces nouveaux compères apparemment il a
choisi les bons thèmes pour gagner sa
vie place du tertre
il faut présenter ce qu'on appelle des
classiques parisien il faut quand même
toujours avoir un peu là l'église saint
cloud sacré-coeur bon parce que les gens
viennent quand même chercher beaucoup de
souvenirs plutôt que d'après lui
réellement cessé
reste maintenant à fixer les prix je
pense que je vais faire
les petites 60 ça ça va être 150-200 550
mais pour certains anciens ce que vont
le petit nouveau n'est pas assez chez
jeanne d'arc
mais il faut plus que ça or c'est bien
pour cesser mon premier jour donc là
j'ai pas moi je pense que ce sel puis
c'est ce que j'achèterai je pourrais pas
dépenser plus je me mets du côté client
est bon je vois ça ce prix-là givon
pourquoi pas j'essaierai de le baisser
encore un peu d'ailleurs et s'il veut
gagner sa vie il va falloir travailler
sérieusement
ici tout est histoire de calcul vu les
petits fruits que l'on fait on peut pas
se permettre de mettre huit jours pour
faire une toile quand vous faites une
toile en deux trois heures c'est
c'est rentable sur table et on est on
est dans la rentabilité car sur la butte
se déroule une incessante guerre des
prix dans les galeries des rues
avoisinantes
des toiles sont proposés à des tarifs
surprenant on trouve ici des tableaux
parfois quatre fois moins cher que ceux
de la place du tertre
comme ces petits formats vendu 15 euros
pour arriver à des prix aussi bas
ces commerçants se fournissent auprès
d'un gigantesque réseau en caméra cachée
nous jouons les touristes et enquêtons
près des vendeurs ce sont des pales du
calcul
oui cela aussi c'est des fans de catch
et ça c'est un artiste du gagnant le
match commence au tableau et la police
et le rouge à chaque fois les vendeurs
nous assure que ses toiles unique sont
réalisés par des peintres locaux
pourtant quand on se présente comme
journaliste le discours change un peu
tout ce qui est paris
enfin une commerçante nous lâche le
morceau s'est pas fait en france et ça
vous le dites aux touristes ben non
pour eux c'est des français la muraille
qui sont persuadés que c'est dépendre du
coin les masters qui servent que ces
bons français ça chez nous donc on ferme
d'autres biens ou dit rien mais que ce
soit fabriquée en service tout en forme
de coeur vous dit rien et quand ils vous
demandent si c'est fait dans le coin
ouais je leur dis que c'est fait
d'accord même si ça n'est pas l'homme
juste mais bon qu'est ce que ça coûte
tout à fait la vérité quand même
mais alors d'où proviennent ses toiles
dans une dernière boutique
nous finissons par obtenir la vérité
c'est fabriqué au sud pour
trois cars viennent de chine ainsi ce
style 100% montmartrois et fabriqué par
des chinois à l'autre bout du monde dans
des ateliers bien loin de l'esprit de la
butte direction d'apple dans le sud de
la chine
à deux heures de train de hong kong
c'est la capitale des toiles bon marché
nous sommes au village des peintres 60%
des tableaux à bas prix vendus aux
touristes dans le monde proviennent d'
ici chaque jour jusqu'à 10000 peintre
s'activent dans des centaines d'ateliers
une des plus grosses entreprises de la
région a accepté de nous ouvrir ses
portes
nous nous rendons dans ses ateliers de
peinture c'est ici dans cet immeuble de
quatre étages
jane ou la responsable nous montre que
l'atelier est capable de produire des
tableaux de tous styles
ici c'est notre salle d'exposition ces
tableaux là sont très appréciés par les
américains c'est plutôt moderne on peut
les accrocher dans le salon ensuite il
ya des commandes de clients allemands
c'est un style plus anciens se sont
surtout des tableaux connus
ça c'est pour un client hollandais des
acteurs célèbres des chanteurs pain dans
un genre pop art est ici ce sont des
vues de paris en noir et blanc commandé
par un client français dans cet atelier
les peintres peuvent répondre à toutes
les demandes
ici il est en train de peindre mona lisa
ils sont embauchés en fonction des
commandes
ils peuvent être 120 à travailler à la
chaîne
chacun sa spécialité pop art vue de la
méditerranée ou monuments de paris
voici celui que l'on appelle le
professeur cayes une sommité dans cette
entreprise depuis dix ans il ne peint
que des monuments parisiens comme le
moulin rouge
même s'il n'a jamais mis les pieds en
france c'est vrai je n'ai même plus
besoin de photo je peux peindre comme ça
j'ai même pas besoin de faire un dessin
et vous aimeriez aller à paris ah ouais
j'y ai pensé mais pour l'instant je n'ai
pas assez fin pour réaliser ce rêve
écailles n'est pas qu'un vulgaire
copistes comme beaucoup d'autres ici il
est diplômé des beaux-arts sa dextérité
ferait pâlir d'envié certains peintres
de la place du tertre pour tester son
habileté
nous lui demandons de reproduire le
sacré coeur
d'après une photo que nous lui apportons
elle est difficile cette peinture oui
elle est compliquée il ya beaucoup de
détails dessus même pour une toile comme
celle ci qu'elle n'a pas besoin de faire
de dessin préparatoire il va directement
au pinceau un peu de temps ça va pas se
perdre comme ça et puis il faut
s'appliquer parce que sinon à l'arrivée
on y voit plus rien et un peu de sens
pour lui afin de réaliser ses toiles de
50 par 60
ces trois heures
un résultat impressionnant prix de ce
tableau moins de 10 euros ils seraient
revendues environ 50 euros en france les
ouvriers viennent de toute la chine chen
jun a fait 850 km pour gagner sa vie ici
dix heures de travail par jour pour 300
euros par mois
il est plutôt content car ces revenus
sont au dessus de la moyenne
c'est mieux que de travailler à l'usiné
c'est beaucoup plus souple ici si on
travaille plus il y a une grosse
commande on peut gagner davantage l
usine les salaires sont fixes alors
qu'ici les salaires c'est parfois plus
parfois moins on peut gagner jusqu'à 20
euros par jour alors que l usine c'est
moins de 4 euros par e-mail toutes ces
toiles sont ensuite emballé sur place et
expédier dans le monde entier cette
entreprise exporte plus de cent
cinquante mille tableaux par an
principalement en europe et aux états
unis
21h30 les ouvriers qui plein travail
chen jun et les autres peintres sont
logés juste en face dans des locaux
sommaire loué par l'entreprise leur
espace se limite à une chambre chaque
soir ces jeunes s'entraînent encore à
dessiner et pas n'importe qui pourquoi
vous dessinez le président mao est
intéressant de le dessiner
c'est un personnage très important et
cette production se retrouvent sur les
étals de montmartre des toiles quatre à
cinq fois plus cher en fonction du
nombre d'intermédiaires
mais le xviiie arrondissement est le
théâtre d'un autre commerce plus obscur
est tout aussi rentable
celui de la drogue château rouge la
goutte d'or des quartiers réputés pour
le crack la drogue du pauvre
nous rencontrons hakim la cinquantaine
cet ancien héroïnomane fume du crack
depuis 20 ans il se réfugie dans les
toilettes publiques
[Musique]
c'est le coin cuisine avec du
bicarbonate dessus donc ces faits au
bain marie
vous avez fait un peu cheap les
comprendre et lacaisse com
je me suis enfui du caillou là je suis
en train de le faire four sur le filtre
le crack un effet plus violent plus
intense que la cocaïne mais aussi plus
court 4 à 5 minutes seulement
vous enfumer de bien pâles à jour
moi j'ai d'espacé parce que tu es
il aurait leaf après il faut souhaiter
s'il vous fait même de son c'est le
championnat qui reprend une bière
d'autres disent qu'ils aiment le skénan
est un médicament un antidouleur
puissant pris pour soulager les cancer
en phase terminale
beaucoup de fumeurs de crack l'utilisent
pour contrer les effets secondaires
dévastateurs de la drogue c'est compris
hakim fume une quinzaine de minutes
et s'ils s'installent dans les toilettes
publiques c'est pour être plus
tranquille j'ai moi personnellement je
vais pas faire et ce que je peux en
afrique sharp ont rejoint aux enfants
aux femmes
c'est déjà arrivé à l'ancrage à bord le
quotidien fait rappeur peur des
toxicomanes mais surtout des dealers ces
petits trafiquants pourrissent la vie de
certains commerçants
c'est le cas d'isabelle chercher ce qui
l a monté un atelier de couture salon de
thé qui est parti en fumée
là c'était le coin couture ici c'était
salon d'essayage y avait un rideau et là
c'est le coin cuisine
voilà donc voyez le coin cuisine était
comme ça ah oui c'est très clair et très
lumineux c'est les gens qui ont entraîné
la dengue disais c'est un havre de paix
au milieu du quartier
la boutique d'isabelle at-elle été
incendié par des dealers
rien ne permet aujourd'hui de l'affirmer
une enquête est en cours pour le
déterminer
chez empêcher de faire leur deal dans le
sens où il y avait des gens comme des
gens comme vous et moi normaux qui est
rentré dans l'atelier qui forcément été
gêné par les drogués qui étaient dehors
donc au fur et à mesure et bien il a
bien fait parce que quand j'ai ouvert il
ya trois ans j'avais 40 drogué devant la
porte
j'avais la pop qui était fermée à clé en
permanence et puis un jour j'ai dit
maintenant j'en ai marre je le droit de
respirer moi aussi donc j'ai laissé la
porte ouverte
mais après ça a été une bagarre parce
que parce que je les laissais pas
rentrer à l'intérieur parce que je
voulais pas leur réparer leurs jeans
gratuitement parce que je leur donnais
pas du coca gratos voilà alors incendie
criminel ou accidentel
aujourd'hui je suis parti il est vrai qu
isabelle chercher ce qui est aux
premières loges du trafic de drogue à 20
mètres de chez elle les toxicomanes
viennent acheter du crack
quand on faisait des travaux on voyait
les neuf les dealers qui donnait qui
donnait la gamme des petits pépins comme
ça et qu'elle est portée par ce que lon
quand ils se rendront peut rien leur
faire avant l' incendie isabelle a été
cambriolé deux fois mais elle refuse de
partir elle veut rouvrir au plus vite
malgré une ambiance de quartier parfois
dur à supporter
les associations estiment qu environ 500
consommateurs de crack se concentrent
dans l'arrondissement beaucoup fume dans
la rue ou les halls d'immeubles
pour éviter les problèmes de voisinage
une association a vu le jour
coordination toxicomanie ces trois
éducateurs de rue sont chargés
d'améliorer les relations entre les
habitants et les drogués
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ils ont été appelés dans cet
hymne des résidants se plaignent de la
présence de toxicomanes dans les parties
communes
les éducateurs cherche des traces de
consommation invisible pour un oeil
inexpérimenté une fiole de sérum
physiologique
c'est un indice et puis aussi ce bouchon
sur le dernier jeu quoique quand on
allait sur saint denis cet été les
dealers c'était là dedans qui mettaient
leur le krach comme ça quand il y avait
une descente de police et que je faisais
fouille ils n'avaient pas de krach
plutôt furieux s'était caché dans dans
des bouffes les meilleurs informateurs
ce sont les habitants les éducateurs
tentent de recueillir des témoignages
ce n'est pas toujours facile ici
beaucoup ne parlent pas français
un tiers des habitants du quartier sont
des immigrés et beaucoup sont désabusés
rien n'a changé une situation que
comprennent tout à fait les éducateurs
d'heureuses ils ont fait appel à la
police à la mer etc soit ou non qui est
passé quand nous en arrivons quand se
présente comme étant une association ils
se disent la mairie la police n'a pas pu
faire les choses commente association
vous allez faire des choses une solution
serait de mettre des codes aux portes de
sécurité les vitres sont cassées sur
place les éducateurs explique aussi aux
habitants comment se comporter face aux
toxicomanes les usagers quand après
avoir consommé
les sons sont amplifiées savait qu'il
suffit juste que vous élevez un tout
petit peu la voix et son impression que
vous leur crier dessus et de ce fait là
ils vont vous être agressif avec vous le
conseil s'est donc de chuchoter mais les
éducateurs savent bien que s'ils
sécurisé cet immeuble ils ne feront que
déplacer le problème
les toxicomanes s'installeront ailleurs
car ils sont partout dans la rue la
journée on ne les remarque pas forcément
c'est là que les éducateurs vont les
chercher ils les connaissent bien ils
leur font d'église serre des mains avec
un objectif les aider au quotidien
m bonne fête de l'aïd à verser angèle
par exemple ne sais pas où dormir ce
soir
ce soir ce soir ça va être chaud elle a
déjà passé la nuit dernière dans un hall
d'immeuble et au swing gadjé tc1 rue
pajol amateurs moi c'est un centre
d'hébergement d'urgence
si à des places ils te prennent
aujourd'hui et qui est pour tout le week
end jusqu'à lundi matin
9 heures oui bonjour j'aurais voulu
savoir si vous avez une place pour une
femme pour ce soir ouais merci au revoir
et il a dit que tu peux passer à 21h30
au cas où il ya un désistement peut-être
que tu auras une place les éducateurs
sont sollicités pour toutes sortes de
problèmes ce quartier à quelques
encablures de la butte montmartre
ils le connaissent comme leur poche un
inquiétant supermarché de la drogue
chaque rue a sa spécialité dans
certaines on ne vend que du crack un
marché tenu par ce qu'on appelle le mode
ou des dealers venue spécialement
d'afrique mais des jeunes du quartier
ont voulu les concurrencer des bagages
et des coups de couteau il ya eu des
relevés des règlements troupes et en 12
ans
vous n'êtes pas chez vue dégagée c'est
chez nous et ils ont repris le marché
mais avant de reprendre la marche et ont
d'abord côtoyer les modos pour apprendre
pour savoir comment faire pour cuisiner
pour tous et après ils ont dégagé et à
deux minutes de là sur cette artère une
spécialité les médicaments un toxicomane
nous explique à partir de midi
oui tous les produits que tu trouve en
pharmacie les usagers ils ont des
ordonnances y reviennent ici puis
revendre et c'est comme ça depuis qu'ils
achètent leurs cracks cette situation
alarme les associations car les
médicaments sont utilisés comme de la
drogue
nous rencontrons un dealer ils vont du
subutex un produit de substitution à
l'héroïne
là
non
le baptême
ouais
ça
il ya les gars là
mais tout à coup un de ses clients
s'approchent
[Musique]
avec
combien quoi par exemple
les arrow
comment vous
l'auteur certains médecins sont
complices des dealers il leur délivre
des ordonnances l'an dernier 24 médecins
et pharmaciens ont été poursuivis par la
justice
isabelle chercher ce qui quant à elle
essaie de relancer sa boutique c'est
toujours dans le même état là ça va
bouger
ah ben non ça va bouger c'est toujours
la même
faire que trois mois et son propriétaire
la mairie de paris n'a toujours pas
commencé les travaux
alors aujourd'hui elle se lance dans une
action coup de poing
elle a carrément décidé d'interpeller le
maire bertrand delanoë lâche part en
guerre et je sacrément remonté à ce
matin le maire de paris va inaugurer un
lieu culturel le centquatre
elle veut attirer son attention sur sa
situation et surtout sur celle du
quartier
elle rejoint des amis mais c'est loin
d'être gagné il y à la police partout on
change de trottoir
ce partage est quand même là on va aller
de l'autre côté aussi inique aucune
chance non je disais pas que vous aviez
aucune chance je vous disais que les
chances sont minimes
et pourtant elle veut absolument
remettre au maire une lettre en main
propre cana alors chacun va se poster
sur le passage de bertrand delanoë
une personnalité belle monsieur la
situation est bloquée ses amis tous
habitants de château rouge sont partis
en croisade pour soutenir isabelle si
vous vous promenez dans le quartier rue
myrha et c'est à vous allez voir il n'y
a pas grand chose il ya un marchand de
journaux qui s'est installée grosso modo
il a du mal à tenir il ya un caviste bon
grosso modo il aussi du mal à tenir
cc c'est un quartier qui se sa pauvre is
it met plus un quartier populaire c'est
un quartier qui se ghettoïse qu'il faut
refermer
car il n'y a pas que la drogue qui
bouleverse ce quartier la misère
omniprésente n'arrange rien la moitié
des ménages et non imposable et c'est un
des arrondissements de paris où l'on
trouve le plus de logements insalubres
cette famille par exemple habite un
appartement de 12 mètres carrés
ils en ont honte et veulent rester
anonymes en fait ça c'est les petits
coins cuisine
oui à le boot à gaz en dessous donc à
mes petites affaires dedans parce que
j'ai pas de placard d'un petit plat
comme une équipe vers un goûter pour les
enfants et tout ça donc voilà juste
après le salon immelt à la chambre donc
ça c'est le salon et la chambre donc en
mange ici
et eux et en débarrasse la table et on
dort ici
et voici la salle de bain ils vivent à 5
dans ce logement
un couple et trois enfants de bain un
petit coin pour la machine à laver
chaque jour pour cette mère de famille
c'est la même galère
donc comment enlever tout ça tous les
jours et tous les soirs ont enlevé des
coussins angot mettre la table au fond
comme ça on va mettre le ghos à la voilà
donc on met ça eh ben mon mari là et moi
là et les deux fils à bas et donc en
fait on a plus de place on peut plus
bouger
faute mes enfants et parte je remets la
table comme elle était comme simple et
je rends mais là tout d'abord est pour
ce logement ils payent 365 euros
pourtant des cafards cours sur le sol
les murs soit d'humidité et surtout
l'appartement est extrêmement sombre et
un de la lumière s'il vous plaît
derrière vous on est plein jour il ya le
soleil et 1d vous allez voir alors vous
voyez cgt encore l'autre il fait on est
tout le temps allumé la lumière tout le
temps n'ait atteint un mythe histoire on
assure temps la lumière allumée parce
qu'on est dans la cour et dans la cour
n'a pas de celle plus grave encore ce
logement est dangereux pour les enfants
car les peintures sont au plomb la
petite dernière à force de toucher les
murs est intoxiqué les médecins ont
diagnostiqué un saturn is une maladie
qui peut entraîner des problèmes au
cerveau cette famille 8 ici depuis huit
ans elles attendent désespérément qu'on
réponde à sa demande d'une hlm
[Musique]
pourtant ce quartier est en pleine
réhabilitation le 18e c'est un des plus
grands chantiers de paris ici des
logements sociaux on en construit à tout
va objectif améliorer le cadre de vie
mais ça prend du temps
quatre ans en moyenne pour la
construction d'un immeuble et le
quartier conserve sa mauvaise réputation
insalubrité drogue et surtout
prostitution
ces jeunes femmes les policiers les
appelle les marcheuses elles sont
habillées comme toutes les adolescentes
doudoune jean pur à première vue rien ne
laisse penser qu'elles sont prostituées
[Musique]
marché c'est leur parade contre la loi
interdisant le racolage
[Musique]
mais dès qu'on les arrête il n'y a aucun
doute possible on va bien
elles sont partout à château rouge des
africaines souvent très jeunes en bande
comme des groupes de copines nous en
rencontrons plusieurs sait combien en
marche d'accord on marche de quel côté
elles ont toutes moins de 25 ans
certaines sont mineures
beaucoup viennent de pays politiquement
agitée ou extrêmement pauvres prévient
doux ghana nigeria sierra leone sierra
leone
oui et au vu du ghana nigeria la plupart
ne parlent même pas français
selon le ministère de l'intérieur
beaucoup de ces prostituées sont
victimes de trafic d'êtres humains
des rabatteurs leur promettent une vie
meilleure en europe un petit boulot et
elle se retrouve ici
cette jeune femme par exemple toi tu
l'appui combien de temps ça fait presque
demain elle dit avoir 18 ans avec cinq
ou six autres prostituées
elle a été installée dans un appartement
de chambre et des toilettes
toutes les pièces sont occupés par des
jeunes femmes avec leurs clients mais il
ya quelqu'un là oui tu aimes ici où tu
préfères là dedans ça va ici pourquoi tu
fais ça on l'a forcé à faire oui je suis
forcé de le faire
ce n'était pas ce que j'avais à l'esprit
je le fais parce que j'ai besoin
d'argent
si je pouvais je ferai un vrai boulot un
boulot normal de force
oui mais pas assez pour avoir des
papiers non pas pour les papiers
je le fais parce que je n'ai pas le
choix si j'avais utilisé mon propre
argent pour venir ici je n'aurais pas à
le faire
je ferai un travail normal alors ton
boss à payer ton billet oui et toi tu
lui donnes l'argent que tu gagnes chaque
jour
oui et et combien tu dois les données
chaque jour cette jeune femme ne veut
pas en dire plus nous n'insistons pas
une particularité de la prostitution
africaine c'est que les boss les
proxénètes sont en général des femmes on
les appelle les mama elle organise tout
et font venir les jeunes filles en
france
les prostituées rembourse ensuite une
dette en moyenne vingt mille euros et à
20 euros la passe il leur faut des
années
la prostitution dans le 18e
arrondissement ne se trouvent donc pas
forcément où on l'attend
traditionnellement qui disait
prostituées 10 et pigalle mais les temps
ont changé
le boulevard n'est plus qu'un ensemble
de cabaret un peu poussiéreux avec les
photos figée de femmes des années 80
mais les sex-shops autrefois tabous
attire aujourd'hui une clientèle
décomplexée c'est la mode des sex toys
ce jeune couple à la découverte du
quartier a dégoté un petit accessoire
fort intéressant alors l'appel à la rue
mouais ça nous intéressait d'aller
acheter un peu là pour ça donc on va
profiter du point c'est un jour où on a
vu les artistes ont eu lieu qu'au foot
on regarde ce que ça pas on prend un
verre on a mangé et puis je la veux
rentrer à la maison
faute de quoi c'est tout le temps comme
ça et si certains magasins anormal au
toulon droite comme chez carrefour elena
l'habitude
elle travaille ici depuis 20 ans elle a
vu évoluer la clientèle plus de jeunes
plus de fans
mais selon elle pigalle a perdu son âme
les gens s'attendent à voir toujours
autre chose
à pigalle pas que des boutiques et par
des choses qu'on voit dans les quartiers
chauds par exemple ou encore les gens y
trouvent plus rien les hommes surtout
sont un peu paumé son père mais il
trouve plus rien et repas spectacle
trouve pas un 4e ticket trouve pas une
fille trouvera et ont pu rien les trous
plus rien les hommes elles sont tombées
ouais sont déçus
non y'a plus rien applicables
[Musique]
pour helena pigalle est aujourd'hui
devenu un quartier comme un autre
la population a beaucoup de chance
d'abord il ya beaucoup d'enfants
il ya énormément d'enfants alors si vous
venez l'été l'été le le milieu là il ya
que les enfants qui jouent avec les gens
qui sont assis sur les bancs mais il ya
énormément d'enfants alors qu'avant les
voyez pas c'est inconcevable
inconcevable vrai
à pigalle maintenant on se promène
l'allée centrale a été rénové et arboré
et les catégories sociales supérieures
investissent peu à peu le quartier
ces agents immobiliers sont spécialiste
du xviiie
ils connaissent les lieux les plus
magiques la particularité de cet
arrondissement la voici
il suffit de pousser une corde pour se
retrouver dans un océan de verdure
[Musique]
impossible depuis la rue de deviner ce
jardin ultra protégée
vous avez atelier maison en atelier vous
avez des immeubles typiquement
montmartrois avec mélangés avec des
immeuble en briques rouges 19 centres
et vous avez des ateliers d'artistes
dans toute la toute la résidence est
vraiment un lieu ça ça parle ça parle
tout seul dans cet immense espace privé
les prix flirte avec les 10 mille euros
du mètre carré façade monumentale vous
élégante et à l'intérieur vitraux style
art déco
[Musique]
voilà
au double séjour un appartement de 140
m² haussmannien classique mais donnant
sur pigalle un bien très recherché par
un nouveau type de clientèle
les bourgeois bohème c'est à dire qu'ils
viennent chercher aussi sa set c'était
de paradoxes en étant sur le boulevard
pigalle avec les les peep show les mains
et c'est ça qui les amuse sétifienne ils
viennent chercher ça hein
l'originalité ici dans ce très beau beau
quoi s'est il aime bien ces il ya un
côté qui est très populaire
voilà c'est à dire qu'on vit dans un bel
endroit où tu en es tout en gardant ce
côté populaire avec ses nouveaux
habitants
pigalle est devenu un endroit branché
mais le quartier continue d'attirer une
population sulfureux il ne s'agit plus
de grand banditisme mais de petite
délinquance violente aux motos cuir
rasé et l'autre grande de grand isle et
shoah les policiers de la bac du xviiie
sont sur le qui vive à partir de 5
heures du matin à la sortie des boîtes
de nuit
il observe les comportements suspects
[Musique]
ça court je les ai pas de précipitation
parce précipitation ils ont repéré deux
jeunes qui ont accosté un coup il s'agit
peut-être d'un vol
nous titillons bobby en beauce pendant
ce temps des policiers à pied en civil
interroge le couple on vérifie les
cartes bleues car il ne leur manque rien
fausse alerte cette fois ci de plus en
plus de bandes de cités descente sur
pigalle pour dépouiller les fêtards qui
sortent de boîte on leur pose là un
groupe d'une dizaine de personnes
intrigue les policiers
on a une petite embrouille à je pense
que c'est entre potes bon à voir il ya
une bonne bande là au niveau de la place
pigalle s'acquitte le secteur va ça va
prendre le métro ça va prendre le métro
immédiatement les hommes de la bac les
prennent en filature
autre contrainte de plus un jeune est en
train de se faire agresser de l'autre
côté du quai
la bande est en train de lui faire les
poches
oui
auclair selon ils sont en train de faire
un mec les entrants sont restera un
exemple probant
on distingue alors en contre qui trois
jours seulement
les policiers décident d'intervenir
allez c'est parti bonjour messieurs
c'est la police tout le monde contre au
mur vous sortez tout ce que vous avez
dans vos poches rapidement rapidement
tous les portables la victime la voici
une proie facile
cet homme est complètement ivre il lui
manque un téléphone et un baladeur mp3
les jeunes aurait aussi volé un autre
portable avant de descendre dans le
métro
ils viennent d'une cité du nord de paris
ils ont tous moins de 25 ans l'un d'eux
est mineur
recherché pour fumer ils sont amenés au
commissariat pour ce vol avec violence
car la victime aurait reçu des coups
il risque jusqu'à cinq ans de prison et
75000 euros damende à condition que la
victime porte plainte
ce qui n'est pas toujours évident dans
le souci des victimes malheureusement
c'est que des souvent comme elles sont
éméchée elle refuse de déposer plainte
donc pour nous c'est assez frustrant
parce que on assiste quand même des
choses répréhensibles et sans le dépôt
de plainte de la victime
malheureusement la plupart des auteurs
s'en sortent facilement
ces vols c'est une grosse partie de leur
travail quotidien
le reste les policiers les appels des
pigalle à lever du jour sur la place
pigalle
tout commence par une arrestation ce la
presse tu peu de gars est plus complète
on contacte pour sortir de ce couple
aurait agressé un homme c'est au palais
d'état l'énervement et tout le monde au
poste
cette galerie c'est des gens qui ont un
petit peu trop consommer qui se
comprennent pas bien souvent qui se
connaissent en fait c'est la plupart du
temps c'est un différend en fait et ils
trouvent pas la solution donc il ya des
gens qui crient qu'ils appellent la
police il s'agirait d'une arnaque
cet homme affirme avoir donné 200 euros
pour passer un moment avec une femme
qu'il pensait être une prostituée
une jambe yves laporte cible
mais petit jeu là beaucoup d'enjeux
je suis parti voir le gym enfants les
vieux du coup les policiers tenteront de
régler cette histoire à l'amiable quand
tout le monde aura des soul et le
commissariat du xviiième est celui qui
détient le record parisien des gardes à
vue car dans cet arrondissement
toutes les extrêmes se croiser
isabelle chercher parce qu' elle a
remporté une partie de son combat un
mois après son action coup de poing et
des dizaines de lettres de harcèlement à
la mairie elle déménage ouais ça va
mieux
dans quels cas de macabres et bonjour je
m'installe là la mairie lui a proposé un
nouveau local pour son atelier de
couture à deux pas dans une petite rue
plus tranquille voilà vous avez visités
[Musique]
et quelques jours plus tard l'atelier
est enfin prête
ce matin j'ai tourné en rond tout le
temps et puis puis là je n'arrive même
pas faire un seul pantalon
le soir c'est l'inauguration les
habitants du quartier sont venus
nombreux comme provisoire c'est bien là
c'est bien arranger les clients vont
pouvoir revenir
il ya quand même un petit truc sympa en
attendant la grande nation car isabelle
n'abandonne pas sa lutte
elle veut retrouver son ancien atelier
avec la réhabilitation du quartier
elle espère qu'une nouvelle population
s'installera ici plus jeune plus aisés
qui changera le visage et la réputation
de cette partie du xviiie arrondissement
à deux pas de la butte montmartre et des
touristes
[Musique]